treer trying to get free clutch shot
callus Traer hits the three-pointer as
the quarter comes to an end he got it
off in time
nice little fake clearly got it off and
suck
o3o once again takes it to the rim Trier
steps back his jumper rattles home
off the bench seven points in ten
minutes he's 3 for 4 from the feeder
getting a real good run each plate 11
that's already feel their mix with a
little momentum right now traitor
it's a little more pep in his step
previously Knox wheel and appeal and
this time career shaking and baking the
Knicks get a David Fitts Dale waving his
arms push push push
yeah fascinating pace now tria what's it
in here now 5 of 6 from the field right
here the deepest has improved more guts
tone the office 314 footer and getting
tangible results with this shooting
conversely tears the only link with the
neck right down man widenar he's got 6
of 7 from the field
sensational rejection there to the
basket
watch Frank that's the rejection sphere
swoops and hoops Dudley was there but to
no avail
and smear swoops and hoops Dudley was
there but to no avail
[Applause]